you shot this in Los Angeles I'm curious
Joel you're riding around in a squad car
and you are dressed as this alien
creature this orc like creature you're
wearing can we see actually what you
were wearing you're wearing a ton of
makeup and yeah whoa what did first of
all what was that makeup like well first
of all is important that you cover this
face you know what I mean yeah
why it looks so much like my face is
[Laughter]
important to cover your face it looks
like it's pounds of makeup it's three
and a half hour or three like Chris who
won an Oscar just immediately after we
finished for Suicide Squad
it was my makeup artist and it was we
got it down in like three three hours
but what's interesting is it's running
around with this fella yeah no I mean it
was it was it was it was chocolate it's
like he's being like really - it was a
it was a message 3/4 of an inch
knocking to him give that direction and
sweat is just squirting out of his ear
yeah yeah I'm back now though I'm back
now and I had a nickname for the makeup
it was so fat the couch the couch the
couch because it's the farm laid up but
what's interesting is is is the power of
this fellow because like you're driving
around and like I'm a monster driving a
car downtown who are watching both of us
riding in a squad car down you know one
of the boulevards down there and they
don't like yeah this monster driving the
car but hey will you see monsters every
day but I thought every day you see Will
Smith
you